die Klima Kleber die Nerven nämlich so
richtig und Bild nervt jetzt zurück
genau gesagt ja unser unser Bild
reporterik Schütze der erstmal auf die
Straße gegangen direkt zu den Klima
Klebern und hat versucht die von der
Straße weg zu nerven
so sie kleben wieder hier mitten in
Berlin aber heute heute wird zurück
genervt
hi willst du gemütlich
[Musik]
beantworten wenn sie mit einer Person
von uns sprechen wollen Theo sitzt da
drüben ja der kann ja ruhig herkommen
ach guck mal sie kriegen ja schon Besuch
und bei euch läuft auch
wir haben heute überlegt wir machen das
auch mal so wie ihr wir Nerven mal ein
bisschen zurück
und da habe ich erstmal eine Flöte
mitgebracht
[Applaus]
[Musik]
und nervt schon ein bisschen
wie geht's dir schon ein bisschen am
Nerven
gut ich glaube ich muss noch ein
bisschen weitermachen
[Musik]
ja das mit dem Flöten kriege ich noch
nicht so hin sie sind auch irgendwie
immer noch hier dann gehen wir zu Phase
2 über ich habe einen Freund mitgebracht
der mag den Klimaschutz genauso wie ihr
und den setze ich jetzt hier mal hin
Kleber Kleber Nerven Klima Kleber Nerven
[Musik]
es wird auf jeden Fall aufgelöst ihr
seid aber irgendwie hier noch stur bei
der Sache und die Sitze hier weiter
fleißig rum aber der Verkehr der geht
weiter sind nur [ __ ] sind bitte ganz
einfach
was sollen die sollen sie 10 Minuten
hinsetzen sollen sie Fahrbahn frei
machen wir müssen arbeiten die Idioten
je näher arbeiten
ist ja richtig weil ist ja nur für uns
für die Umwelt und alles also man ist
zwar dagegen aber und wie haben der
recht wir und sind meine Enkelkinder und
die Kinder von meine Kinder und und und
und du schon wieder hi zu bemerkt wir
sind echt berühmt geworden seit gestern
und ich habe dir auch wieder mal was
mitgebracht weil du gestern schon so
nett die Bild-Zeitung gelesen hast daher
schenke ich sie dir heute wieder
[Musik]
das ist natürlich ein sehr ein Thema was
was stark du diskutiert wird und
dementsprechend vertraue ich einfach
darauf dass Menschen da sind die für uns
eintreten würden kannst du Blockflöte
spielen kann ich nicht nein ich spiele
mal was vor weil wir hatten so ein
schönes Gespräch die anderen die wollten
sich einfach nicht mit mir unterhalten
die waren da irgendwie relativ
verschlossen und meine Freundin da
drüben die habe ich gestern schon
getroffen die hat heute wieder nicht mit
mir so richtig gesprochen bei dir spiele
ich jetzt ein Ständchen vor ist okay
[Musik]
ich kann es ja mal versuchen
das Mittel das kommt im Gitarrensolo
relativ ähnlich so also es ist noch
Hoffnung für mich
so ich bin wieder da sitze immer noch
hier sag mal ich zeig dir mal ein Video
das ist von euch sogar da habt ihr so
ein bisschen kunstgeschendet kennst du
das
[Musik]
Tomatensoße auf dem Van Gogh das war
voll toll oder findest du das
[Musik]
gut das nehme ich mal als ja ich habe
nämlich übrigens auch Tomatensoße
mitgebracht mir gedacht ja das könnt
guck mal hier habe ich auch eine gute
Tomatensoße
das ist so ein bisschen die Frage was
kann man denn mit dieser Tomatensoße
alles anstellen
komm da hast Du eine Idee was man damit
machen kann
mir fällt also ganz viel ein dann machen
könnte such mal die Farbe des Banners
ist ja schon mal da riecht auch gut
jetzt mal riechen
sehr lecker aber so bin ich nicht keine
Angst ich werde sie nicht über dich
rüber schütten das macht ihr ja nur ich
würde sagen ich nehme die wieder mit
nach Hause und ihr beschmutzt keine
Gemälde mehr wollen wir das machen
[Musik]
wir warten noch auf das Jahr
wird am Montag wieder da vorbeifahren
unser Bild Reporter
[Musik]